There's Hope and there's expectation the
reason I wrote jab jab jab right hook
it's so important give give give and
then ask not take or expect I'm super
thrilled to ask but when the answer is
no or I can't I'm like you know where I
weirdly go compassion it's empathy on
empathy on empathy non-expectation the
reason you're smiling left and right is
there's people that probably really let
you down on your hope like when I said
that right now two or three faces
flashed in front of your head but when
you don't have expectations you can get
over it you doesn't mean you're not like
to your homies like that [ __ ] Rick's
such a dick does Rick not remember I
[ __ ] introduced him to the hottest
girl he ever hooked up with like I know
like there's people that said no to me
that I [ __ ] put onto an investment
that they made 10 million dollars on and
they couldn't buy a hundred of my books
they made 10 Milli hope and expectations
two different things when you learn how
to separate that [ __ ] you get real happy
real fast